It's hard work, working with people like Anya
and Mimî, because they are just
constantly trying to fuck me up.
I love to laugh on set,
and I love to have fun, and-
the good thing is that Henry is also
like that. And he’s very good at it,
I don’t know if he’s a stand up comedian
or what you know, it’s like...
he’s a very funny guy!
Henry will turn around and say
some shit, and you’re
just like, arhhh…
we're just about to do this thing.
Why you got to throw us off like that?!
And he will just come out with these one liners,
he's like the king
of, like, these dry one liners,
and they just
have you in tears of laughter.
At your final breath, a shitless death.
But I doubt it.
Eamon gets up to some shenanigans.
So if I’m with Eamon, who plays Cahir, we’ll probably laugh the whole way through
because he is just the ultimate joker,
and he's a tease as well
and I'm very guillble. So that's-
that’s a really funny combination.
Ahh we’ve all got an inner joker. I’d say
Eamon is the joker.
He loves it, he loves making people laugh.
Shut up.
He's hilarious.
He's just on fire all the time on set.
He's just so funny.
Anya and Mimî are just ridiculous,
and they always try to distract me on set,
but I am a constant professional.
I'm the serious one.
We were walking, I don’t know what we were doing there to be honest,
but we were walking,
and there was these like boulders
everywhere you went, so you couldn't walk.
And the director at the time, Sarah, she was like “What’s wrong with you guys?”
“Can you not just walk?”
And we were like struggling
because our ankles were just getting
destroyed.
Afraid to break a nail princess?
I'm from the north of England originally,
and being back in the north of England,
Jaskier...
was for the first few takes, really-
Geordie and I had turned to Henry
and I was like “Do I sound a bit Geordie?”
And he was like,
“Yeah, you sound weird, man.”
You need a nap!
A lot of our views
and perspectives
have all been green screened.
So me and Eamon will show each other little
video clips of what we're imagining.
So it'd be like, “Oh, I'm imagining
Kanye West singing Happy Birthday
to Dave Chappelle.”
Yas is pretty bad
because he would always come up
with different nicknames.
He started calling me Lambchop.
Good old Lambchop!
They just kept it in because they
they liked it.
Just a bit of fun.
Henry and I have a small game
where usually
if one of us leaves a take
and we're still in the scene
we try and pull faces
at each other to try and make each other
laugh.
He's got a really good number of just leaving a take, like looking really serious
like Geralt,
and then just as he,
leaves frame, he'll just go-
Me and Paul are on set...
there's always something going on, always,
there's always some sort of trick or prank
that everyone's playing, especially
with Freya as well,
because she's so competitive.
Maybe, I might even let you win.
Pfft, yeah, you wish.
There was one scene
that we were filming recently,
and I think it's
when Cahir enters Cintra.
At the end, there’s like this face off
between the three of us.
And like the cameras just kept on rolling
and it felt like an eternity.
We were all in character,
just staring at each other.
But Eamon was on the other side
of the camera, so he's just staring at us.
And then he's like,
like that, and he’s just doing loads
of funny things,
he's just brilliant.
Look, it's hard work
working with people like Anya and Mimî
because they are just constantly
trying to fuck me up.
Sorry.
Excuse my language, but,
you know, Anya is constantly yelling at me
trying to get her tea for her.
It seems mages are merciful.
Mimî is like, you know, making faces off
camera so I don't get my close up
right. Like, it's a nightmare dude.
Like...it's a nightmare.
I do find it really funny, though,
because obviously we're not actually fighting
these monsters, they’re you know,
big puppets, or stunt men
in blue suits! So sometimes you find yourself laughing a little bit.
So the first time we saw them come in,
it was like these two guys, like
in these blue rubber suits. And me and Paul-
I looked at Paul
I was like, “Who let the condoms out man?”
It's so funny.
Big foam heads with, like,
stunt men in blue spandex.
It's so good.
Aqueducts because... it was testing conditions
because we had to be in the water,
visualize this monster.
But we had so much fun.
That was one of my favorite scenes
to film,
for sure.
Training Ciri in Episode 3.
Freya, you know, kind of challenging
Lambert and testing his authority.
What did you do then?
And then taking control of the situation.
Cahir and Yennefer are sort of in the middle of this square.
And they arrive, sort of above ground
and they sort of
have it out together and they share,
I think,
I mean, you know, Cahir and Yennefer
are pretty closed off people,
I think they're pretty protected people,
and so for the first time, I think
because they're strangers, they kind of
are the most emotionally available
that they've ever been with anyone.
Everyone answers to someone eventually. Even you I suspect.
Fringilla...
she finally gets to have a bit,
just a little bit of revenge.
And we've also got this
character called Hake.
He's a general,
and he is winding her up, galore.
Like everything that she does, he's
nit picky on it.
He keeps throwing her
under the bus in front of Cahir.
And you call yourself a leader…
She’s just had enough, so she gets to come in
and basically kill all the generals.
Whenever a lesser light tries to steal what is yours you do not sit there and take it.
It's amazing.
It’s such a fierce moment.
My first scene I think that I shot was
me and the big man, farting about by a lake.
It was the first time I'd seen HC for-
for a year over the pandemic.
So it felt really like coming home
and it was so easy to slip back in.
Each of your faces is cause enough for celebration.
You’re safe, you made it back, you made it home.